so we have another new record of the
Southern border Customs and Border
Protection reporting more than 2.3
million migrant Encounters in the fiscal
year 2022 which ended last month that
includes 98 people
on the terror watch list Texas
Republican Dan Crenshaw just went to the
border to assess the situation first at
firsthand and he joins us now good
morning to you I I see no end to this
I'm I've been looking for answers trying
to figure out Solutions here and
there's none inside is there
no there won't be an end to it until
there's policy change and the policy
changes are pretty simple you have to
disincentivize Illegal immigration uh
you know I noticed Biden's press
secretary saying yesterday that this
isn't really their fault that they you
know they're they're dealing with an
unprecedented crisis it's a very
different kind of immigration crisis
than past administrations have dealt
with that's just not true it's just not
true at all the difference is they
incentivize it because they make it very
clear to anyone who crosses illegally
that they'll be given a bus ticket to
anywhere they want the U.S they'll be
given notices to appear which don't have
a lot of legal teeth and people might
appear in court they might not and they
usually do not and so obviously there's
a huge incentive to get in now while the
getting is good that's that's that's the
word that has spread the cartels helped
spread that word and they help coach
people they take a they take a fee from
anyone who crosses and so everybody's
making money on the southern side of the
Border especially the cartel so this by
Administration is empowering the cartels
which by the way are also uh smuggling
fentanyl across our border to the tunes
of thousands of and thousands of pounds
which is enough lethal doses to kill
every American many times over and we're
not talking about this like it's like
it's a violation of our sovereignty or
our national security this
Administration has completely failed us
it's almost as if the fentanyl is a
weapon of mass destruction and you
fought in the War on Terror and here we
have the statistic that 20 uh Terror
terrorists on the terror watch list
folks were found in September of 2020
and then 98 this fiscal year
and 20 alone in September excuse me so
right I'm just thinking about how
American taxpayers
are willing to pay to be protected from
terrorist attacks and we spend a lot of
money on it we've tried we've worked
very hard to make sure that we are
protected from terrorists and now you go
to the border from your perspective
you've fought in the War on Terror how
outrageous is it that you have it's just
basically wide open and 98 can come
across and nobody blinks and the White
House doesn't say anything
and those are just the ones that we
happen to be tracking and we're able to
catch so you know it it was obvious to a
lot of us that before long the the word
would get out to terrorists around the
world that the easiest way to get inside
the United States uh is through these
border crossings remember those are just
the ones we caught there's plenty of
others that are getaways border patrol
is constantly tied up with groups of
hundreds of people that the cartels just
push across and these are people just
turning themselves in they know they'll
be let loose under the interior but
there's other people trying to get away
and you have to wonder if it's so easy
to get in and stay in why are you trying
to get away it's usually because they
have a criminal record or they're part
of a cartel or they're part of a gang or
they're on the terrorist watch list and
they know it and so this is a huge
natural security threat and we don't
even talk about these cartels like their
terrorist organizations which which
indeed we should I mean there's almost
80 000 Americans dead every year from
fentanyl alone and that is directly
related to to basically two cartels the
Sinaloa and Jalisco cartels and nobody
knows who the leaders of these cartels
are it's not plastered across our
newsrooms and it really needs to be
people should know who El Mayo is people
should know who El mencho is these are
the leaders of these cartels that are
murdering Americans poisoning them
lacing fentanyl with street drugs and
and and and just they're enemies of the
state and we have to look at it that way
you gave a speech the other day and you
said uh we don't control the border the
Mexican Government doesn't control the
border the cartels do and you're right
about that this is where they make their
money in partly on behalf of smuggling
human beings the fentanyl sees the
Border in the past year 14 000 pounds I
you know it's
um
it defies understanding as to why we
would allow it
and I just you know I'm even down there
you know this you live in Texas
what justifies the policies they've had
for the past two years
well from our perspective nothing of
course it's it's dereliction of Duty
it's uh dereliction of their
constitutional duty to enforce the laws
that's their logic
how do Democrats think about this look I
think there's a few things I think some
cynically believe that the more people
they LED in the better their electoral
chances are in in the in the far future
now you're seeing the wave of Hispanics
changing Republicans that's probably not
true South Texas is turning very red
because of this but I I also think they
don't respect sovereignty or borders
just as a general rule they have this
sort of like outsized pathological sense
of compassion where where they just they
they they see poor people who who want a
better life in their life well we should
just let them all in now those of us who
are more rational and say well there has
to be some sort of line I mean whether
they're just they're supposed to just
cut in front of the many many many other
people who also want a better uh life in
America but are doing it the right way
that's immoral that's unethical and it's
an infringement on our sovereignty we
don't really we don't even have a border
we don't even have a country of just if
there's no standards or process
whatsoever and so as usual Democrats
feelings get in the way of their
rational thinking and that's that's
usually what happens here and you're
seeing it in and play out right now
all right thank you so much Dan Crenshaw
it's good to see you thanks for going
down to the border and coming back here
to tell us all about it thank you sir
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis